in tonight's whatever happened to
the tea party the political movement
emerged from a place of dissatisfaction
very high dissatisfaction over high
taxes government intervention
increased debt and more correspondent
kevin cork takes a look back tonight on
a movement
that ended up making a difference
they were patriotic principled partisan
and for a time quite powerful the tea
party
forged in frustration fed up and
fighting mad
mad about sky-high taxes mad about
government spending run amok
it's as if they were somehow channeling
both howard jarvis and howard beal at
the very same time
the former the late california tax
activist the latter
of network movie fame i'm as mad as hell
and i'm not gonna take this anymore all
of which gave rise to a political
movement
that once counted among its key
supporters a veritable who's who
among american conservative lawmakers so
dissatisfied with the pace of change
they demanded
they took on the gop party establishment
spearheading
opposition to government-run health care
and helped republicans take back the
congress in 2010.
emboldened they later helped to
orchestrate a government shutdown
and even forced the ouster of house
speaker john boehner
but much has changed since then the
house tea party caucus is now long gone
so too are nearly all of the 87 2010
house republicans
elected in the biggest gop wave since
the 1920s
undone say critics by budget deals that
unraveled spending strictures
placed there by tea party republicans as
well as congress's decision
to suspend the debt ceiling the tea
party is no more
fiscal conservatives those who remain
should be in mourning
and yet the fight continues trillions in
spending thanks to the global pandemic
and exploding debt up from 13.5 trillion
in 2010
up to 27 trillion today would seem
sufficient ingredients
for a tea party resurgence but with no
proven recipe of sustainability to
follow
the party's past could well prove its
epilogue
rather than a primer for its rebirth
however
with 3 million contributors and
supporters still backing tea party
groups in 2021
supporters brett tell us that theirs is
a movement with plenty of power to yield
and to wield a power that could by the
way prove even more potent with midterm
elections afoot in less than two years
and that playbook from 2010 to
potentially dust off
brett kevin thank you